i actually became friends with this girl
one time just to [ __ ] her brother
[Music]
this episode of answer the internet is
brought to you by showtime more on that
a little bit let's get to the questions
hey it's bella danger and i'm back to
answer the internet if every time you
finished sex a song played what song
would you want it to be um i guess cry
me a river or like
well you should be sad that it's over if
a guy matches with his best friend's
sister on tinder should he pursue it um
yeah just like don't tell him about it
but like because if because if she
matched then she wants to [ __ ] him too
so like
i don't know are guys like offended by
that do you guys not most guys don't
want their friend to [ __ ] their sister
really yeah believe it or not yeah but i
felt i felt my friends brothers and they
didn't care
and they don't care
well i don't know
i'm not still friends with the girls
that i [ __ ] their brothers
i actually became friends with this girl
one time just to [ __ ] her brother
and then i did let her know that her
brother had a really big
are the reasons why you don't want your
friends than your brothers to [ __ ]
i don't get it it can be any guy or a
girl for you okay would you be celibate
for a year to be able to have sex with
any girl you wanted after the year was
up but like only have sex with her once
no you you yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
that's the thing i could do [ __ ]
somebody could you like whoever it is um
no
no because i have like
most people will like slide into my dms
but i will like admittedly say that i
have slid into certain people's dms who
did not even open that chat and i'm like
[ __ ] how am i going to [ __ ] this
yeah
it was very humbling
i'll show you
very humbly i was like dan did you aim
really high were you like
what the [ __ ]
i feel like i feel like yeah i wasn't i
thought it really humbled me because i
thought you thought you're like
like i'm the [ __ ] yeah i know i'm not
not responding right yeah that's
definitely that would really i mean my
ego would you go celibate for a year to
[ __ ] that person
no
[ __ ] that
two buttons you can only press one
instantly get a million dollars
or you have a 50 50 chance of getting
100 million dollars
oh my gosh i don't know if i consider
myself a lucky person you ever like one
won the lottery or i've never gambled
i'm very scared about it like i'm brave
yeah so i was just it's like but man a
hundred million also for you it's like
you're good if you know without it you
know what i mean like you have 100 uh
yeah i guess i would do the 50 50 chance
i'll do that one yeah
gonna gotta go big or go home would you
would you rather what a watch your dad
[ __ ] a hundred year old woman
or b watch your mother kill someone oh
you're a 100 year old man i would rather
watch my mother kill someone straight up
like
like
my mom like she's very she has a very
strong personality and especially with
girls like all my girlfriends like she's
so shady with them and stuff like she
loves all my guy friends and hates all
the girl and so i could easily imagine
her killing one of them
i wouldn't want to see it i know exactly
which friend she would kill too like i'm
telling you my mom will walk into the
room and she's there and she'll be like
ugh she won't even acknowledge this girl
she's like your mom hates me
really doesn't like her
is eiffel towering a chick with another
guy gay i feel like you know just limit
the eye contact um
yeah because then it's like if you're
staring into their eyes it's just very
strange
um but i don't think it's gay i think
it's just like
yeah if you're like if you're like
making eye contact you're definitely
like on the scale if you're just like
looking at the girl it's not gay at all
it's like straight so depending on the
eyes yeah like if we're like this like
yeah and we're like
like
then but if you're like looking at her
then
you
know
yeah it's just something else it's just
like whatever [ __ ] this other guy if you
could see a sex tape with any two movie
characters who would it be
oh my gosh a sex tape with any two movie
characters
but just so hard there's so many good
ones i feel like i would do this chick
from kill bill and and bill like i would
want to watch them focus he's i like the
daddy vibes that he has
and then she's really hot and i feel
like i have a i have a foot fetish and
if quentin tarantino shot it it would be
like so much feet in it and
yeah i would be vibing with that you got
to get in a tarantino movie
i would love that
just so i could see my feet if you could
live inside one tv show what would you
live in damn i feel like
it would definitely be like shameless
because
it would just be so chaotic and like
interesting but then i wouldn't want to
because the way the living conditions
are set up aren't that ideal
yeah so but like everyone is so
interesting in it that i feel like oh my
gosh i would love it so maybe um you
want to like hang out with the cast of
shameless yeah
over here yeah like live from oh my god
like he's so hot like [ __ ]
um
dang so
hmm
definitely like
the oc
like the original like oc that seems
more like the lifestyle
um adam brody guy or uh oh you know adam
brody adam bernie yes adam brody for
sure
so [ __ ] hot like if he was single
yeah oh my god 100
yeah seth cohen is like daddy like he's
so cute if you had one free throw oh if
you had one free throw
you tell i don't play basketball
if you had one free throw and you had
and you made it you get a million
dollars but if you miss you never get to
text again would you shoot it [ __ ] that
i wouldn't even take that chance because
i need to text no
okay but how far the free throw line
right it's like that thing
no no that's the three-point line it's
like the one where you get like multiple
chances to do it okay no i wouldn't do
it anything like 20 million no 50.
maybe for like 100 yeah i mean for 100
million
how much money is in your bank account
of the show would you rather bang a
bunch of models but nobody knows or not
actually [ __ ] them
but have everyone think that you did i
would definitely want to actually [ __ ]
them then like no and nobody knows
because that's literally
every sexual encounter i've had in like
my personal life i don't want anybody
knows right yeah yeah so my question is
if you know that a guy or if you think a
guy has [ __ ] a bunch of models does
that make you want to [ __ ] it more no
really no that's community dick like
that doesn't really like interest girl
like there's just nothing bad about it
but like
i wouldn't it wouldn't make me any more
it would have made me less inclined but
not definitely not more inclined like
that's what most girls think or do you
think most girls are like oh my god he
like [ __ ] all these smoking hot chicks
so i want to be like i want to be on
that list or i don't know how girls
think i'm not like really like a normal
girl
i think i think more like a guy than
like a girl
would you rather suck one dick for 50
000 or get
one thousand dollars for every dick you
suck but it would have to be a different
dick or every time i sucked the same
dick so you could suck one dick one time
fifty thousand bucks or you got every
time it's a different dude the one day
one time fifty thousand cause then i
would have to suck
fifty one thousand
okay
i have a math class coming here
yeah but yeah so think about it you're
gonna you're gonna get paid to be on set
anyway and now you get an extra thousand
bucks every time you blow somebody
you'll get to 51 pretty quick no
no that's less than what i get paid to
what is your
well it depends there's like different
it depends like because my contract gets
renewed every year so like we negotiated
so like based on how many times they
still could take a month it's like a
monthly okay so so how it works is like
i have a monthly quota that they that i
have to make that like they have to
spend yeah so i so i have to shoot right
so i have no like so i have to shoot a
certain amount to get paid a certain
amount yeah so like
depends it's it's very complicated
you okay
that's the worst thing you like joke on
your space it goes down the road less
traveled by whatever it's called would
you rather have your porn search history
shared with your twitter followers or
your parents i mean definitely this is
like such a dumb question for me
obviously my twitter followers
like well i don't know you sounded
yesterday you were saying there's some
[ __ ] you don't want
oh i guess then the whole world would
know
yeah okay well i would definitely show
just my mom she would be really
disturbed but like you know she loves me
so she has to like just kind of deal
with it but then
the twitter followers yeah i guess
you're right i wouldn't
yeah but now my dad the word does he's
excluded from this this is what what is
the weirdest thing you've jerked off to
i'm not going to tell you
i don't know i don't want to be judged
it's got to be like is it like illegal
is it like are people getting beheaded
no it's just i don't know some things
are sacred okay
mary [ __ ] kill italian food mexican food
chinese food okay i would definitely
marry italian food
and then i would [ __ ] chinese food and
then i would kill mexican food like
italian is like my favorite and then
chinese is my second favorite and i
could just live without
mexican food like honestly like mexican
food isn't like taco bell was like my
favorite mexican food i feel like it's
just the same like five ingredients i'm
like yes i love taco bell
how far are you willing to drive for sex
i drove 10 hours for sex one time what
what yeah i did
this was like last summer
you should drive zero miles
okay okay okay
yes
from miami from miami to destin which is
on the panhandle
so it's like it's by pensacola it's
right pensacola
yeah so it was 10 hours just in florida
we drove there and jovac well because it
was a pandemic the flights were super
limited he drives to you
but we were all meeting up there
like because it was it's fun it was fun
okay listen when
when the whole world was closed down
destin was a place to be out because
they really never like
i'm just being quite honest like it was
you got to feel like you were in the
normal world there but the reason you
went was to have sex the reason i went
was solely to have sex if that man was
not going to be there i would have not
gotten like i literally just out of fame
no i'll be like if it was a famous
person i would have been like yo coming
over like send me a jab like something
would you [ __ ] the ugliest teacher
you've ever had to be able to also [ __ ]
the hottest teacher you've ever had you
know it sucks because i never really had
like a really hot teacher
so
i gained nothing from this yeah i never
i never well they're like older i'll
tell although you guys know what they
look like i'll like i'll like steal
pictures of them i mean i hope one of
them is hot that would be very
interesting
if someone texted you a picture of your
vagina with no contact would you know
it's your vagina no i have and i've
actually like looked at a picture of a
bunch of vaginas before it was like a
collage someone made and tagged me
like in it on twitter it was just like a
collage of a bunch of porn star vaginas
and i was literally like which one is
mine
i didn't know
i didn't i didn't know you're the only
person who's ever gonna answer this
question honestly and especially in a
sea of like vagina like
dude i was i was stuck i still i was i
was never able to figure it out mary
[ __ ] kill brad pitt matthew mcconaughey
channing tatum okay this is so easy mary
brad pitt [ __ ] matthew mcconaughey
and then um kill chinese tatum really
so easy
oh my gosh because i'm obsessed with
matthew mcconaughey and he's a scorpio
so i know he would be so amazing on sex
because i'm a scorpio and then brad pitt
is just like the sexiest thing ever and
then channing tatum just like does not
do it for me whatsoever i didn't feel
the magic with my ink if you were
married who would if you were murdered
for how to read um who would be the most
likely suspect
oh my god probably all the girls that i
[ __ ] their brothers
that was perfect
oh my god
all right thanks for watching i got one
last question for you who would you
rather fight jake paul or tyron woodley
leave a comment below on who you'd
rather get in a boxing ring with on
sunday august 29th that's the next big
pay-per-view brought to you by showtime
pay-per-view and most valuable
productions it's the problem child jake
paul versus a former ufc champion tyron
woodley if you want to be in the
building you can go to
rocketmortgagefieldhouse.com and get
tickets and if you're going to watch at
home go to the showtime app or
showtime.com
ppv to buy your pay-per-view today let's
get it on
i hope you enjoyed that video i'm about
to dance don't answer the internet
subscribe right
leave a comment below with who you want
to see next and you're [ __ ] welcome
i even kind of tried to block it
[Music]
the tip hurts this time it's like he got
the tip and the balls
oh that was
it was so much harder than mine
it wasn't so sweet
it feels bad we've got some velocity on
that one